now wake me up before you go-go don't
leave me hanging on like a yo-yo
sorry everybody just wanted you to know
the song that magnus carlsen sings in
his head before the start of every game
this game being no exception against
grishnack from the 2015 world blitz
Chess Championship again that ultimately
proved critical night of 3c5 and then
III we are headed toward a little bit of
an unorthodox move order approached by
Carlsen
Grichuk decides regular development
makes the most sense then after Knight
f6 Carlsen and media plays d4 g6 and
then c3 buy Carlson ultimately leads us
to this structure here which is a very
solid structure for white it's a Tori's
type Zuka torque type London type
structure where this big dark Square
pawn chain here has the intention of
maintaining a very solid and stable
centre with the idea of maybe putting
the bishop here and getting an attack on
the King side but because Grisha played
the fiend kettle system with the bishop
coming to g7 that's going to make any
chances for white to launch a successful
King side attack on this diagonal much
less the bishop is sort of biting on
granite so as you can see after the
moves g6 and b6 Carlsen decided to pause
and take a think here he wasn't exactly
sure how he wanted to approach it keep
going into a zoo Couture type structure
or maybe open the center and play for
something a little more flexible perhaps
try to punish the fact that this
diagonal has now bend open and on that
note Carlsen took on c5 and play d4
pointing out exactly the features of the
position that I just described the
knight cannot take on e4 because Queen
to d5 would provide a fork to the knight
and the rook on a8 ouch town right
Grichuk has to pause and think for a
moment because if he can't take this
pawn then he knows he's dealing with a
much more dangerous structure for white
out of the opening the pawn on e4 might
even just go to e5 on the next move so
pausing to think for a minute also
enjoying himself some Wham in his head a
fun song that everyone likes to sing
grishnack apparently included in that he
decides to just play Bishop to g7 sort
of calling White's Bluff saying well if
you play e5 I can likely put my knight
on g4 and I don't see any immediately
crushing tactics so we'll see if you
want to waste that much time in the
opening rather than just developing your
pieces Carlsen isn't sure about it or
maybe he's thinking of his his second
favorite 80s song
but the game that happens in the middle
game here is very equal for both sides
and we see critical play with both sides
fighting over the D file here in a
moment
ultimately it was a very back-and-forth
game until we get to the endgame where
some of the real fireworks are going to
start so if you're just joining us for
this video and thinking out do I really
have another seven minutes to kill let
me tell you something you have seven
minutes to kill because this is Carlsen
Grichuk Robles chess championship Bishop
to d3 Carlson develops a piece prepares
to Castle just like his mama told him to
Grichuk is thinking well is there a
reason to strike in the center perhaps
with a move d6 or d5 decides against it
castles wrecker oka castles King side
for Carlsen as well and both sides now
feeling that they've gotten out of the
tricky part of the opening you're going
to see that the next few moves are
developed a little bit more quickly a
little bit rapid fire since they're no
longer worried about immediate tactics
on the diagonal and Grichuk feels that
most of his dangerous problems are gone
since Carlsen didn't go for a 5 early he
plays d6 Carlsen thinks about it both
sides really taking their time to at the
early stage of this game more than other
blitz players behind them as you can see
by Sheila Robin Kramnik Bishop e7 rook
to e1 Knight B to d7 and now h3 a solid
sort of bigger picture waiting move
freeze the back rank maybe prevents
black from bringing this Knight to g4
and e5 but really it's kind of asking
black what his plan wants to be because
if black pushes this e pawn to the wrong
square the structure then changes for
white advantageous ly the D pawn will
then be backward and there may even be
opportunities for the knight to target
it so he has to be careful with that
Grichuk doesn't want to play d5 on the
other hand because of e5 and then maybe
even e6 so as you can see Grichuk is not
exactly sure yet of which plan he wanted
to take here and pausing for a few
moments he reconsidered right now
Carlson's next few moves if given the
opportunity will be a little more
natural he's going to bring out the dark
square Bishop he's going to likely to
either f4 g5 as we see here he did go to
f4 to prepare e5 Grichuk responds with a
4 trying to make this b to pawn backward
as a potential target and Carlsen calmly
plays Queen to d2 completing his
development officially as beginners
would know because the brooks are
connected
Grichuk plays bishop
see six a useful move on several fronts
one it supports the apon so that this
rook can freely leave it and maybe put
pressure here but also prepares a long
term idea of a potential battery with
this Queen and Bishop on this tag and
I'll remember that idea of boys and
girls because it comes back to haunt us
after work a 2d one Queen to b6 we see
the Grichuk has two plans gang up on the
b-pawn and again this idea I already
mentioned of the battery happening but
overall the position is got a favor
white as long as it opens up a little
bit with all these pieces being prime
Lee developed in the center
Carlson agrees and says it's time to
play e5 I'm going to invite some
exchanges because I'm hoping that my
more coordinated pieces in the center
will will pay dividends as files and
diagonals open up but Grichuk either had
this in mind or simply found Queen to be
7 over the board my guess is he was
preparing this idea all the long as I
foreshadowed would Bishop to c6 because
now Carlson's will put a little bit on
the spot he doesn't really want this
Bishop to come back to f1 where it's
passively defending the g2 pawn that
might even open up central light squares
but playing f3 could have long-term
negative effects on the dark squares in
the end you'll notice that he hopped the
ops for the latter and though I think
the game is still very equal from a
practical perspective we slowly head
toward a time scramble where White's
King ends up being a little bit more
open than black which you can say yay or
nay whether you agree with me but I
think it had something to do with the
the messy tactics that occurred later on
despite just the simple fact that we all
know Carlsen didn't maybe have his best
chess going in Berlin back in October
but Carlsen eventually decides on the
ladder as I said with f3 Grisha quickly
puts a rook on the D file and Carlsen
unpinned the bishop obviously there may
have been threats as long as the plane
remained there the game gets under time
pressure here in the next few moves
we're going to see that rapid-fire chess
has to happen if you're evaluating this
position on bias Lee I still think it's
just about dynamically equal White has a
small positional edge because blacks to
isolated pawns over here the C and the a
pawn and maybe even White has a
three-on-two but because of whites
potentially open King on these diagonal
squares as highlighted and the fact that
black has no other real permanent
weaknesses to show I think the position
has to be considered more or less equal
rook to c8 followed by Knight to c4 and
then Bishop to d5 Bishop comes back to
f1 both sides are sort of putting their
pieces on squares that are protected to
make sure that nothing bad happens
Bishop takes g7 Knight takes g7 and
a lot of simplification happening
quickly given that the players took a
lot of time over last few moves and now
we have an arbiter who's clearly not
conscious of the fact that we're trying
to watch a chess game here thanks buddy
thanks for moving on rook to d2 was
played now it's time to trade according
to griffith but let me tell you
something the problem with this is this
is right up Carlson's alley he has a
bishop for a night with pawns on both
sides of the board typically the bishops
will be better than the Knights in those
types of endings especially with the
three-on-two advantage but as I said
don't forget that the open White King
may be the practical factor that
eventually causes Carlsen to blunder
he played b3 sorry I jumped ahead a
little bit that mr. Arbor - there threw
me off but eventually we're in this
position you see here live with Grishka
intending to head into the dark squares
Carlson hoping to simplify and use his
two-on-one advantage a few more moves
are played quickly here and that's
exactly the kind of thing we get you
Carlson decides it's time to play b4 and
use my extra B pawn I should be better
here right it's four on four but I'm the
first person with a passed pawn and I
have a bishop for the night you might
normally agree with Carlsen but again
the white King is open after Queen to c3
and rook d2 we see Grichuk has
intentions to come after the King on the
dark squares rookie two allows rook to
d1 and that's a little bit dangerous
right the bishop is pinned and we know
that could lead to some weird tactics
Carlson is in trouble though because he
doesn't want to unpin on the first rank
he'll just lose the rook
besides that aggressive measures must be
taken in place g4 after g4 grishnak is
going to trade and then bring the knight
into a more dangerous Square all of a
sudden it seems like tactics are flying
theoretically this position should be
just fine for white even if he had
played rook take c7 believe it or not
but after rook e3 Queen to c1 and then
rotate c7 position gets much more
dangerous for white rook to d2 was
played and Carlson plays the ultimate
blunder of the game Queen e3 could have
been met by Queen to e1 Boomtown Knight
takes f3 king h1 and rook H to mate but
guess what
none of them saw it you can tell I've
been waiting to say that this whole time
and boom goes the dynamite Queen to e1
it could have been checkmate but okay
that didn't happen Danny rejoined
reality after the move Queen e3 was
played instead of that of course as
we're getting to here the the move
Knight to e6 was played instead rook to
e8 check King to h7 ultimately the white
King still
being run it ran out into danger the
current light position saw Knight to g7
where both the bishop and the rook were
hanging Carlson had to play Bishop g2
Knight take c8 allowed Queen to c7 check
and here comes the attack on the dark
squares if black trades Queens it's over
don't say I didn't tell you so guess
what Queen f6 black traded Queens and
picked up the b-pawn you see Carlsen
brings in the bishop hoping to stay with
the position with the bishop for the
draw rook bishop for the rook draw but
after g5 trading up pawns is not a good
idea mainly because there's no way white
doesn't lose the g5 pawn before the g6
pawn Carlsen stands up shakes his head
and clearly clearly had ejected a
dejected Carlsen and with that Grichuk
signed the score sheet and the game was
over just to back up and give you a
quick instructive moment of what
happened there since I lost the way in
my am I getting caught up in the moment
of boom goes the dynamite after rook
takes a 7 black could have also played
King f8 immediately but rook t2 was a
practical move that makes a lot of sense
Queen e3 as I said could have been met
by the brilliant Queen e1 as I pointed
out but with 92 check played it from a
practical perspective blacks moves make
a lot of sense Knight f4 by the way is
not take oblique uhz it's a discovered
double check 96 is still threatening
moves like rook G to check winning the
Queen so even with computer analysis
showing criticism to blacks moves that
he could have won faster like for
example here Queen to g1 again was
probably a little more accurate than
Knight take c8 Grichuk really played all
the best human moves and eventually got
to the sin game where it's easy to win
with rook versus Bishop and that's
ultimately why e1 so congratulations to
grishnack this being probably the
biggest win of the tournament beating
the world champion with black doesn't
happen every single day we appreciate
you we appreciate everybody for watching
and have a have a good one see on chess
calm